hong kong
question un petit peu d'ambiance de ses
bonnes mains je vous donne la réponse et
vous me donnez là qu'elle s'est bien sûr
toute l'actualité du jour je sais que
vous adorez ce jeu chez vous vous jouez
en même temps que nous la première
réponse et une photo de nikos
c'est une photo de nikos juste une porto
de nico nico tout ce que tu veux c'est
juste une photo nikos will où on va voir
oui la question c'est quoi
la réponse est trop tôt de nikos que
faut que faut-il avoir s'est assis la
voir dans son slip à mykonos pour ne pas
faire la course
[Rires]
qu'est ce que j'aimerais bien avoir
comme ça au dessus de mon lit si demain
pour la chaussée les plus écoutées
nombre de ces graves n'ont ni cause ça
va aller je préfère qu'elle soit
amoureuse elle a dit stern a besoin des
conseils à bon oui bah un petit caméo un
peu brun un peu petit bar un petit et on
remercie ça me fait plaisir ça me fait
plaisir d'avoir le même style que mon
apple merci est-ce qu'elle était vendue
en salle des ventes pour une grosse
forte somme d'argent non ça c'est pas
passé sur internet c'est pas un truc qui
s'est passé sur twitter qu est-ce qu
alors qu'est-ce qu'a posté thomas sotto
la carte orange a posté thomas sotto sur
les réseaux sociaux thomas sotto
journalistes qu'on adore 1
hier c'était l'anniversaire de nikos
nikos qui fêté ses 51 ans et qui a reçu
beaucoup de messages sur twitter dont tu
as qui n'est pas passée inaperçue c'est
un tweet de thomas sotto qui a ses potes
avec nikos et qu'il affichait hier en
publiant une photo tout ça mais moi je
trouve beau gosse à françois il est très
beau là et c'était la carte orange de
nikos regarder il est très beau à
montréal et en plus je pense qu'il est
là il va là c'est nikos l'a bien pris a
eu un petit et sans l'autre les deux
c'était l'époque où il y avait plus de
gâteaux de bougies voilà nikos aliagas
merci cher monsieur pour cette photo qui
me rappelle que j'ai été jeune
évidemment le retour de bâton ce racisme
je pars à la chasse aux photos de votre
jeunesse voilà et thomas sotto fais
gaffe aliagas j'ai dû dos tu le sais et
pour se venger nikos a publié une photo
du permis de conduire de thomas sotto
regarder mais thomas sotto il a toujours
la même tête c'est le même
voilà thomas surtout c'est tout leur
maître alors justement on voulait avoir
oscillé des photos des animateurs qui
ont bien changé regardez on commence par
un facile je vous montre et qui sait
vous avez c'est de trouver qui sert gars
facile mais exceptionnelle la tête et
une autre est content de chez vous la
meute
elle a reconnu jean luc reichmann c'est
la médaille et moustache et il a pas il
n'a pas non il a été relaxé camp a été
relooké là c'est un francis cabrel il
est plus beau battant et à scénario peu
moins tard il faisait et fait remarquer
et avant aujourd'hui qu'ils essaieraient
qu'il il raconte aussi je le dis aux
téléspectateurs avant il faisait
énormément maquilleuse qui avait sa
tâche de licence et au bout d'un moment
il a dit eh ben voilà il faut qu'on
m'accepte comme ça exact c'est vrai que
je trouve que il a pas une bonne
initiative sciences humaines et ça
dérange pas du tout et il est très beau
comme ça un proche au chauffeur de salle
chez des guerres éclatent ans était
chauffeur de salle de nagui à la base
c'est lui qui faisait toutes les voix
aussi oublié à la brosse à dents sera
d'or on a dû aller attention regardez
sauver vous reconnaître cette personne
c'est une animatrice regarder chez vous
c'est valérie c'est valérie non non non
elle est très belle
franchement je la trouve magnifique
animal r d sur bon visage on dit
regardez ce beau village quoi elle
encore animatrice aujourd'hui maintenant
alors maintenant elle vendait le vendée
des fleurs et rungis ah tiens qui nous
les a ramenés elle est certes elle seule
tout va tf1 sur tf1 pas pour qu'il
révèle vendre une quétier non non pas
sont inscrits y aller chez vous c'est
tombé ce que dans le public on la
trouvait l'animatrice laurence ferrari
laurence ferrari non non non anne sophie
lapix non mènera sur france 2 non non
non non non c'est une animatrice de tf1
regardez comme elle est jolie
franchement regardez ce visage
magnifique elle a gardé le même visage a
vraiment volé oui sublet non c'est pas
su blé non allez ça oui c'est qui
laurence boccolini
bravo laurence boccolini et oui c'est
laurence boccolini regarder même souri
de même sauvé et elle est magnifique
elle est magnifique c'est laurence
boccolini
alors là regardez ce n'est pas un
inspecteur des impôts les
reconnaissez-vous cet animateur regarder
ces petits mais non mais c'est bien sûr
c'est laurent ok mais là il a 75 ans
dorothée est beaucoup mieux maintenant
regarde c'est que le relooking s'assagir
non mais cristina cordula et le mec à 50
ans avait lâché et se cacher les parler
avec les cheveux avec la moustache
vraiment la glace et en comptant le
maître du lot mais ce riz non mais non
et oui si wayne a compris c'est
incroyable cette tête de laurent ok
allez regarder un proche à regarder un
autre animateur regard des bons d'achat
via ses locaux dont chabal ou les chats
van der elst à manehouarn au père noël
nous ça va nous perdons c'est christian
jean pierre pernaut bien sûr beaucoup il
était beau gosse pas tous en même temps
cyril valery c'était beau et je trouve
très beau se trouve très beau
franchement oui les bleus
les jeunes gars de terrain quoi comme ça
on le reconnaît bien attention regardez
très belle ce n'est pas ma meilleure
amie mais elle est très belle marine
marchande est belle très belle à
regarder moi aussi j'aurais pas reconnue
est lui très belle voix la regardais
toujours toujours belle amie d'isabelle
morini-bosc au regard des alors
attention la regarder il était co de
françois regardez qu'est cet animateur
regardez qu'est cet animateur et que
françois le père c'est exactement je
peux le temps de dire au public
j'ai pas eu le temps du jeu parti comme
ça j'ai pas le temps de revoir mon
public on embrasse juin diallo notre
temps à chaque fois des voix et
excellente animateurs julien lepers
vous avez raison attention regardez
alors là c'est là elle est étonnante
grosse rigolade
regardez ça l'a annoncé qu'ils
s'attendent à ce qu'on se libère et west
ham est rose à la mêlée bac s qu'ils
font ce qu est ce que je te prends je te
prends les aubergistes quoi il est allé
tout simplement faire les comptes david
pujadas et dieu bénisse la coiffure mais
c'est un géant un flic à côté non il
fait à l'optique le policier était
fermée ce sont de belles et et date
david et beaucoup un journaliste on est
super sexy c'est un des meilleurs jeux
pour parler de ce mec
et c'est un mec aucune gentillesse
vraiment saint amand 2 mai et court
beaucoup et j'ai fait un marathon avec
lui un jour
bref un vrai je m'arrête en bon moi j'ai
fait un marathon mais facile c'est
courir après des boîtes de barrage et
que je regardais à regarder regardez la
prochaine regarder la vie tu regardes
dans la vie tu avais regardées l'a8
regardez regardez
elise lucet ne l a pas changé ah ouais
élise lucet sauf que là elle de voir la
voyez là elle d'abord sur michel tomi
complément d'enquêté là je vais enquêter
non mais changer la loi et regardez
regardez une autre journaliste
franchement alors regardez alors on a
plus l'habitude parce qu'apparemment il
dort mal regardé prochain sophie lapix
wemmel a pas tellement changé à les
mieux armées et mieux maintenant
toujours elle a toujours été joli hâle
est jolie regardez regardez le prochain
ça il va plaire à il va regarder ce qui
fait koh lanta daigné regarder qui sait
ça c'est qu'il s'agit brogniart c'est
jean pierre foucault c'est bien sûr
c'est denis brogniart et ouais dénis bra
d'andorre quoi vous adorez les roues ah
mais oui alors déjà pu vraiment ils
n'étaient pas admis m'aurait plu à web
amusez-vous si oui on n'aurait pas pu
mais sans plus tarder à cet âge là
pourquoi manger avec des sceaux aurait
pu se faire non on est de la même
génération
cette foule quoi la belle est très jeune
et pour finir on à benjamin castaldi
jeunes regardent c'est bien sûr son papa
jean pierre ne serait que vous
ressemblez énormément c'est vrai on
embrasse jean pierre est anormal c'est
votre père c'est normal normal plage si
vous ressembliez au clair les chéris la
deuxième réponse il fume en cachette
quelle est la question il fume en
cachette on fera tourner la q vous nous
rejoignez sur ses beats on est en direct
il fume en cachette café café laspalès
dans le paris le film le pari des tuffes
humains dont la sortie sera détruit
toute sortie est définitive
ça y est c'est terminé ça parle ça parle
d'une info qui est sorti large en france
oui c'est en france oui l'info je
voudrais un politique ouest un politique
alors français alors oui quoi là-bas
c'est que que fait
emmanuel macron quand brigitte macro
n'est pas là exactement que fait
emmanuel macron quand brigitte mâcon
n'est pas là alors que beaucoup parlent
de tensions entre le président emmanuel
macron et son premier ministre
il doit revivre le magazine le point
révèle qu'au contraire l'ambiance est
parfois hyper cool entre les deux hommes
imitation de jacques chirac pour edouard
philippe cigarettes en cachette pour
emmanuel macron et même un verre de
whisky attention rappelle que l'abus
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé est
également les boissons sucrées vous
voyez bien sûr manger cinq fruits et
légumes par visiblement je vous le dis
c'est assez détente est ce que vous
trouvez ça bien que les politiques se
détendant public comment parler d'un
instant très rapidement mais regardez on
regarde un petit récap de cette histoire
c'est vrai qu'ils nous ont révélé que
emmanuel macron fumées en cachette de
brigitte regarder ce sont des
journalistes du point qui ont mené une
enquête sur les coulisses de la brouille
supposée entre edouard philippe et
emmanuel macron mais durant leurs
investigations ces journalistes ont
surtout trouvé des informations selon
lesquelles le quotidien dans les plus
hautes sphères de l'état n'est pas
triste
selon l'article pour se détendre edouard
philippe eymery régulièrement faire
tomber son masque de premier ministre
pour se glisser dans la peau de jacques
chirac
une limitation qui apprécie
particulièrement son entourage et le
président n'est pas en reste s'il se
montre plutôt austère lors de ses
apparitions en public dans le privé le
chef de l'état aime pourtant les traits
d'humour plutôt léger loin de son image
un peu coincé et lui arriverait même de
se montrer épicurien d'élus mars lors
d'un dîner avec ses ministres
emmanuel macron aurait même desserrer sa
cravate et se serait servi un verre de
whisky et quand brigitte n'est pas là
les souris dansent
ou plutôt les clubs brûle loin de la
première dame il n'hésite pas à se
griller une petite cigarette
histoire de se détendre décidément la
clope à la coach et la république en
marche
sauf que toujours selon les journalistes
qui ont rédigé ce papier il se cache
pour fumer trop peur de se prendre en
photo ou pire surprendre par brigitte
[Rires]
l'impopularité d'edouard philippe s'est
envolé en deux mois +4 tort ce point le
premier ministre à 57% d'opinions
favorables ce qui fait de lui la
personnalité politique préférée des
français
je vous le dis c'est s'est envolé
pendant la crise du courant d'un virus
et ils ont fait un dîner le 4 mars et
pendant ce dîner le président aurait
desserrer sa cravate au milieu de ses
collaborateurs et s'est fait servir un
verre de whisky et du cognac ou cognac
en europe rappelle bien sûr que l'alcool
est à consommer avec modération et son
abus nuit gravement à la santé
la drogue c'est mal et bien entendu les
boissons sucrées avec oui bonsoir comme
bonnes réponses aux phoques qu'est ce
qu'il ya allez merci
alors ils doivent savoir qu après bien
des hésitations vous allez voir qu'il
contient plusieurs exemplaires regardez
c'est bien parce que c'est toi alors ces
faits supposés riches pour débuter juppé
jour-là manque de poznan en examen ce
jour là il est en retard et il me dit
edouard vous recevez giscard et donc je
le reçois et je me présente je dis que
le directeur général de l'ump est bien
comment cela marche l'ump marchera pas
pour deux régions un chant d'amour de la
première c'est que vous avez vous lu
structuré et la deuxième raison deuxième
raison c'est que vous n'avez pas profité
de la création de l'ump pour vous
débarrasser des vieux barons et c'est
vrai que les doigts philippines a pris
nos côtes incroyable moi je fais partie
de ces gens là je vois partir de là des
gens qu'on me la cote parce qu'on t'a
beaucoup son gouvernement et moi je les
dis laisser l'avion atterrir et après
vous pourrez aller voter parce que les
filles et moi j'aime il ya deux
personnes en communication qui me quand
je les écoute je me dis c'est pas con
c'est edouard philippe et jean baptiste
jebbari ménilmontant qui parle j'ai
l'habitude champagny djebbari je connais
bien ça tombe pas là et ce avec la
comtesse du barry
pour revenir à ce que disait raymond là
où la cote de d'edouard philippe s'est
envolé c'est quand il a accepté de dire
je ne sais pas mais je vois un politique
qui osent dit
écoutez je vais pas vous répondre je
vais pas essayer de vous enfumer quand
je sais bien parce que pas il a dit
d'ailleurs à ses ministres c'est moi je
me rappelle moi en classe quand je
disais je sais pas quand elle monte pas
à kant et je sais pas balle alors leur
compte est le monde alors quand les
anciens présidents se détendent et il
n'y avait pas que faudrait pas que
emmanuel macron on sait que françois
hollande
vous savez ce qu'il faisait pour se
détendre à l'elysée scooter il manger du
chocolat et dieu bénisse
mais je le dis à chaque fois à françois
hollande il est arrivé à l'elysée car il
avait un régime de fou il avait comme
j'aime après il a fait comme j'aime
manger à l'elysée feraient harris et
démonter il est rentré il avait moins 10
kg et des sorties l'on n'avait plus qu'à
rendre la dignité au moc total la
cravate de françois hollande au départ à
lui arrive et la cravate il n'appartient
qu'à nos papillons faire c'est ccbb via
mon ami il a ouvert un restaurant je
vais vers lourdes et l'adedy confrère
nicolas sarkozy puisqu'il des temps
c'était le jogging ou le cyclisme a été
beaucoup ça et on a un extrait c'est
marrant rappelons par est prisé du vélo
mais il paraît que il a un truc qui
déteste le jus de pamplemousse pour voir
apparaître ces andros le berger le
connaître avec nicolas sarkozy sans
l'accompagner mais je crois que la
montée de théoule va être plate forme
hier
à cannes richard virenque en cause de
nicolas sarkozy
la séquence est digne de figurer dans
les manuels de communication politique
comme toi dans paris tours
tous trois le peloton derrière voilà
jamais être rattrapé
voilà et ça ça leur fait du bien alors
communications optiques ce genre d'image
les chéris troisième réponse vu tourner
dans les clae lequel est la question je
vous donne la réponse à l'information et
vous me donnez la question car il
correspond c'est un petit exercice à
faire mais c'est tellement sympathique
la réponse est à l'école à l'école il ne
me dit pas où va la belle brune vous
serez septembre non à l'école n'a jamais
foutu les pieds qui meugle au oui n'a
jamais foutu vraiment sympa en france l
ouis en france oui ou jean luc lahaye
at-il passé son confinement de la
politique ou pas oui on est encore sur
la politique à l'école alors si oui où
jean michel blanquer a fait une bourde
exactement où jean-michel blanquette à
flers où jean-michel blanquette a fait
une grosse boulette
et bien c'est à l'école regarder ça sur
une petite bourde qui n'est pas passé
inaperçu du ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean mi il a visité quelques
écoliers à l'occasion de la rentrée
jean-mi il a même visité les petits
écoliers se lève il a fait l'erreur qui
ne fallait pas faire surtout quand on
est ministre deux alors ça c'est la
boulette
la bourde regard des milices de
l'éducation et je suis venu voir si vous
êtes content en dhr
oui est-ce que vous avez vu pendant les
vacances la rencontre le mans est voilà
et oui oui alors ça ça a fait couler de
l'encré
c'est normal il n'a eu de cesse de
répéter pendant ces deux mois de
confinement règle ça c'est pas de
vacances bien sûr et que les professeurs
soient prodigués encore les cours et
d'un ça et là il fait la bourde de
lapsus il fallait pas que cesse un petit
lapsus et franchement on parlait de
rentrer grave que dans ce merdeux
d'aller manger une blanquette de veau
sur la plage j'avais envié de dire ça la
réponse
le trikini le trikini quelle est la
question le trikini oui le trikini des
coteries et les dérives et les
fabricants de maillots de bain co
concret les fabricants de maillots de
bain de trikini en trikini minimes
concret et fabricant de maillots de bain
bonne réponse valérie bénaïm le trikini
oui ce sera la tendance pour cet été à
la plage le trick ignore si vous ne
connaissez pas mesdames messieurs je
vous dire ça ça va cartonner assez pour
les femmes c'est le trikini vous allez
voir à quoi ressemble le trikini qui nie
alors franchement c'est nouveau c'est
sorti avec le corps d'un virus alors moi
j'ai un mannequin là qui le portent ces
maghrébins il faut le corps
c'est mieux mais regarde pas ma vie
c'est pas ce que c'est
si cet été est encore incertain pour de
nombreux français une chose est sûre la
mode elle a déjà lancé sa prochaine
tendance
une tendance qui pour une fois est en
phase avec la réalité des français et la
crise sanitaire que le monde traverse
si vous avez la chance de passer votre
était au bord d'une piscine ou vous
baigner dans la mer cet impôt pourrait
vous intéresser les créateurs de mode
ont pensé à tout pour que cet été en
vacances les françaises puisse allier
tendance et protection ainsi après la
mode du bikini le maillot de bain deux
pièces voici le trikini en effet une
pièce vient se greffer au maillot de
bain il s'agit bien sûr du masque c'est
une créatrice italienne tidiane ascarat
mundo qui a créé cette collection
d'abord imaginé comme un trait d'humour
face à l'engouement des clients elle est
devenue réelle alors le tri qui dit on
valide ou pas pedro alors et le trikini
franchement c'est pas mal alors paul
avoir le trikini derrière moi voilà les
sassanides et laisser cette jeune fille
que je ne connais pas ces élections
voilà bah écoutez je sais pas où elle
partira cet été mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que sont michel
ça a commencé comme un gag c'est un
internaute kafka fait ça en gags et la
créatrice et lit mais bon sang mais
c'est bien sûr on semble d'où l'idée 2
mais c'est pas si mal
après le modèle est magnifique avec ben
oui la gratte risque ces modèles
d'accord va écouter bab certes qu'un aaa
non sans rigoler non mais franchement ça
fait super beau ni une amie à moi comme
ma soeur qui nous regarde tout ça elle
dit pape sartec alistar tacle après si
vous avez trois 3 pièces et ça demeure
un ensemble vous tromper dans l'ensemble
soumettez string ma bouche je vais vous
dire moi je vous dit vous êtes en
ballottage défavorable au gosier
je voudrais vraiment alors la réponse et
la prochaine réponse et michel cymes
quelle est la question fait un tour de
l'actu avec l'équipe
quelle est la question michel cymes
c'est la réponse bon ça peut être plein
de choses mais il parie sur le
coronavirus que sia qui est encore d'une
connerie coronavirus nom qui veut faire
des études de médecine
ces méchants très méchants qui s'est
encore fait tacler oui mais par qui ah
ah ah ouais ah ça y est je sais et
attendez je vous remets toi qui marine
le pen at-elle tacler ce matin dans une
interview
pas tout à fait d'aller vite je pense
que c'est une politique qui avec
l'émission me semble qu'il s'agit de
marine le pen arrivait le pen a taclé ce
matin à la radio michel roy raison
carrément très bonnes réponses
[Applaudissements]
valérie sur le bout jusqu'à alors pas un
jour sans que quelqu'un s'énerve contre
michel cymes mushkin cymes cette fois
c'est son anniversaire aujourd'hui à
jean michel2 je lui ai envoyé mon cadeau
c'est quoi c'est quoi un livre de
médecine c'est vrai voilà mais ça fait
plaisir ça fait toujours plaisir aux
médecins le vidal appel médecine pour
les nuls
cette fois c'est pas une personnalité de
télé mais c'est marine le pen à la
présidence du rassemblement national
elle est invitée ce matin de
jean-jacques bourdin sur bfm tv et rmc
et alors qu'il l'interrogeait sur le
maintien du premier tour des municipales
sais pas pourquoi
marine le pen c'est chaud on parlait du
premier tour des municipales
evans et michel cymes que paul biya rien
fait a pris dans la gueule voilà
tranquille il est tranquille chez lui
michel 7ème anniversaire muscles une
idée tranquille non monsieur bourdin je
suis dans l'opposition où les
gouvernements qui annule ou qui
maintient oui moi je suis pas là pour
dire aux électeurs
écoutez à mes électeurs surtout n'allez
pas voter aux élections municipales
expriment ou sept escales oui je me suis
exprimé je veux dire ce que j'ai dit non
mais puisque c'est mon procès mais c'est
moi je suis pressé de la situation c'est
pas de la crise transité alors je vais
me défends les contradictions suivront
les retrouve chez nous les nations cette
politique non non non non il ya des
médecins qui ont annoncé ce qui se
passait il ya des médecins qui ont
raconté n'importe quoi comme monsieur
cymes voyez là il ya des différences pas
lâcher désolé et bien en politique c'est
pareil voilà les voilà il arrive et
qu'on doit site investir le bobino
prendre à moi je voudrais en aval à
laleu ça me dérange voilà la c3 ya pas
que lui se pose c'est vraiment c'est le
porte drapeau des conneries maintenant
sans rigoler c'est énorme et c'est vrai
c'est le sait le hanouna du
betty vraie info une vraie info c'est la
première fois que ça m'arrive
photo c'est pas vous alors une vraie
info marine le pen
ils ont fait le forcing justement pour
que les élections des élections aient
lieu
oui il premier tour et même il voulait
même que le deuxième tour c'est facile
après de taper sur le jeu mais les
élections celles qui les voulaient donc
elle même les républicains il voulait
vraiment des élections il va vraiment
amener les gens aux urnes on va voir si
c'est pas bien on va avoir besoin de
vous parce qu'on va parler politique
dans un instant puisqu'on vous politique
afida turner qui sera pris pour parler
des relations entre la chine et les
états unis sera avec nous dans un
instant mais dakar et notre cru
spécialistes géopolitiques et elle avait
des infos elle nous a donné des infos
qu'on a vérifié la donc pour vous dire
elle vous a bien elle nous a bien je
vous dis que les chéris
la réponse est 9996 9996 quelle est la
question
9996 fait de l'argent c'est de l'argent
arrêter de penser à l'argent
oui l'argent s'est passé ça ça tombe pas
du ciel en oui qu'est ce qui est
inférieur à des militants elle est bonne
camaraderie
à ce jour le nombre de conquêtes de jean
michel maire non c'est beaucoup plus
quel est mon cachet pour ce soir à rim
de 1996 ne soit plus au doliprane
alors c'est une performance physique à
une performance physique 9996 c'est
quelqu'un qui a pulvérisé un record du
monde en une heure qu'est ce qu'il a
fait oui castaldi vous avez ouvert les
yeux je suis là je suis non je sais pas
combien quel est le nombre de pompes
réalisé par un sportif pas loin combien
de pruneaux à manger en une heure le
record ou banque du monde par les habs
combien d'abdos a été réalisée en moins
d'une heure je pense que c'est un
sportif qui est qui qui a des abdos
particulièrement incroyable et donc il
faut mettre 1996 pour quelle est la
question vous allez donc combien de
pompe à réaliser un sportif de haut
niveau
[Rires]
concentré caceido un homme at il réussi
à faire en une heure et ouais ça reporte
m'en fous c'est un arc a battu nicolas
un jeune homme de 21 ans originaire du
monde qui a pulvérisé hier le record du
monde d'abdos fait leur corps ils
étaient 2 6788 contraction en une énorme
l'a pulvérisé
regardez ça c'est incroyable mois les
ados c'est ce que j'aime le moins faire
là bas mais l'hommage qu'elle adore mois
khaddam tôt mais quand vous en faites
vous mais qu'elle a aidé aux hormones et
10 mai qu'elle a encore dit régaler
après ces deux mois de confinement vous
avez pris un peu de poids et depuis
lundi vous reprenez doucement le sport
en faisant 10 abdou le matin dans votre
chambre c'est bien mais le record de ce
jeune homme originaire du mans risque de
vous déranger nicolas gaudreau est un
jeune sportif de 21 ans qui est habitué
à poster sur ces réseaux sociaux ses
exploits et cette fois ci il a décidé de
viser plus haut et de s'attaquer un
record celui du plus grand nombre
d'abandons en une heure un record jusque
là établi à 6788 contraction en 60
minutes difficile de faire plus et
pourtant hier en direct sur sa page
facebook
nikos porte times le jeune homme a
réussi à enchaîner 9996 contraction
hu
[Applaudissements]
le précédent record avait été établi par
un bodybuilder tourangeau aujourd'hui
âgé de 81 ans
c'est incroyable et abdou dur à faire
moi franchement les abdos c'est un enfer
c'est pas votre truc non mais c'est pas
du tout mon truc
vous faites déficit merci car au nom
j'ai fait est pourtant qu'à nice vous
devrez en faire des abdos puisque
l'accélération al par duos ont pour
monter au filet tenir une raquette tu
pourras me donner des conseils pour
l'instant tu vas livre et on cacolac
bien non des masques la techno and zinc
or des masques alors des masques quelle
est la question à l'est après on aura
d'autres spécialistes géopolitiques
afida juste après des masques mayotte où
il valait rien
est ce qu'on peut apporter au bal masqué
non ça c'est une affaire incroyable
c'est des personnes qui offrait des
masques et du gel hydroalcoolique à
leurs clients mais quelle personne aux
frais ça alors ça c'est une histoire
incroyable je vous le dis si une
histoire assez folle ça s'est passé en
france dans le bas-rhin juste autour du
rhin oui je crois que c'est des dealers
qui est qui je crois que c'est d'être
nommé c'est un nom le public a toujours
raison la réponse c'est bien sûr des
dealers des dealers aux frais des
masques et du gel hydroalcoolique à
leurs clients et oui coffret des dealers
à leurs clients pour les fidéliser très
bonnes réponses
dorian causse limargue à graben royal
alors lui quatre valeurs ont été
interpellés il ya quelques jours à
strasbourg
regardez ce qu'ils ont fait on vous
racketter rate qu'on pourrait taper
quelle histoire regarde
les affaires sont les affaires et il
faut croire qu'il n'est pas utile
d'avoir pignon sur rue de payer ses
impôts et d'avoir un commerce légal pour
être un bon commerçant c'est du moins ce
qu'on peut en déduire avec cette
nouvelle venue d'alsace c'est dans l'est
de la france que la police a réussi à
interpeller des dealers particulièrement
bien organisé durant le confinement ces
vendeurs de drogue avait décidé de
livrer à domicile leurs clients
habituels mais pour relancer les ventes
ces dealers pas comme les autres ont eu
une idée pour le moins étonnant à chaque
livraison les clients avaient le droit à
un petit cadeau maison un masque de
protection et du gel hydroalcoolique
offert des dealers très attentif à la
santé de leur client souffre en ce qui
concerne la drogue
les délinquants ont été arrêtés en
possession de 35000 euros 1 kg de résine
de cannabis 30 grammes de cocaïne et une
cinquantaine de cachets d'ecstasy
et incroyable cette histoire incroyable
c'est que ça te casse le moral quand tu
sais qu'on a manqué de masque cependant
plein de temps c'est que les infirmiers
dernier milieu hospitalier hospitalier
pardon il manque de masques et tu te dis
des dîneurs distribuer des masses
gratuitement certes on marche sur la
tête
hormis l'ambiance là non c'est un pari
non je trouve qu'il a raison c'est
absolument c'est absolument incroyable
c'est comment on a des fleuristes des
petites annonces un peu comme vous savez
les pizzas minutes en 30 minutes on te
livre etc
il ya une sorte de forme d'impunité ils
ont l'impression que voilà que qu'ils ne
seront jamais attrapé qu' il n'y a pas
de problème quoi c'est assez fou